today we're going to solve a
turning-point mystery it involves a
problem that at first looks like it
can't be solved with the knowledge that
we currently have access to but actually
we can crack this problem we just have
to be a little more creative in the way
that we employ the skills that we've
developed in algebra and calculus so to
introduce this problem I'm going to
start with something very familiar and
that's the function f of X equals x
squared
now hopefully you're familiar enough
with x squared that you can see by my
Cartesian plane we're going to graph
this and a picture is already forming in
your mind now for reasons that will
become clear really shortly I'm actually
only going to graph part of this
function I'm only going to graph the
part where X is greater than 0 so very
roughly I think it's going to look
something like this
now the important thing about this
familiar parabola shape that I want to
draw your attention to is in this domain
there is well an increasing function all
the way there's no turning point in this
domain where it sort of becomes a
decreasing function so this f of x
equals x squared is familiar to us and I
want to compare that to a very similar
looking function has all the same pieces
we're just going to arrange them
differently and that is 2 to the power
of X so if I swap the X and the 2 take
the number out of the index and make it
the base we get an exponential function
and in this same domain well honestly
the function looks pretty similar it
won't have the same intercept at 0 down
here when it passes through the origin
it's actually going to pass through y
equals 1 if this was the y axis but then
from there it kind of like I said looks
similar just kind of has this
exponential growth feel to it now just
like with F of x equals x squared I want
you to notice that this has the quality
of being an increasing function all the
way through in fact 2 to the power of X
even if we looked at it for the entire
domain if we didn't restrict it if I had
a look at this part over here it would
still be an increasing function for all
values of X but in the domain that I'm
interested in where these both overlap
that's what I want you to notice so
we've got let's get rid of this little
bit over here on the Left we've got f of
x equals x squared and then we have to
the
have X now both of these functions this
quadratic and this exponential are ones
we understand pretty well we understand
what happens when you've got X in the
base and it's worth noting if I increase
that power from 2 2 3 4 5 etc if I do
that further quadratic and if I do that
for I should say polynomial because it
won't be a quadratic anymore and if I do
that for the exponential as well and
change these numbers here change them
into you know sorry that's not a number
that's the X if I change this number
here or this number here if I change
them into any other values like 3 4 5 or
you know 7 8 9 et cetera and even though
the scale will look a bit different the
overall shape is still going to be
preserved so these are the qualities
that I'm noticing in these domains and I
might as well write it down so it's
really clear X is greater than 0 that's
the part that I'm interested in for both
of these both of these functions are
purely increasing functions we could
call them monotonically increasing
that's the fancy word okay now this is
like I said what happens when the X is
in the base that's what we have over
here or where the X is in the exponent
or any index like we have over there
what I'm really interested in and where
the mystery comes from is when we try
and combine these two what if we had an
X in the base and also in the index at
the same time now what I'm trying to
think about is a function that looks
like f of X equals x to the power of X
what's this thing going to look like now
we can actually explore this in depth
and I've done this in other places so
you can go and look those up if you're
interested but for now let me just cut
to the chase and show you what the graph
of this thing is actually going to
appear like if I take this function X
well I haven't done anything to it in
terms of powers yet raise that to a
power before I put in the X I just want
you to make a prediction in the
quietness of where you're learning at
the moment have a think about what you
would guess this thing's looks like
remembering what our sort of component
functions look like the things that
we've put in together to make this the
polynomials over there on the left
they've got this upward trajectory and
so do the Exponential's over there on
the right okay
have you got an idea of what you
think these things might combine into
well you might be a little bit surprised
because when we have a look at the
actual result let's put the X up in the
exponent what is going on there this
function and you might have had a guess
at this because of the title I gave to
this video this function has a turning
point what is it doing there
in fact if we look a little more closely
you can see and there's some familiar
numbers here for example if I put in x
equals 1 then the function itself is
going to take on the value 1 to the
power of 1 so unsurprisingly you get
this point over here that's actually
just to plot it 1 comma 1 oops that's
not a plot there we go alright so
there's 1 comma 1 it sits on the curve
you can see as you go toward the right
it's kind of what you expect it just
gets bigger and bigger and bigger those
surprises there 2 squared 3 cubed 4 to
the power of 4 these things are just
sort of skyrocketing right but then
something weird happens between x equals
0 and x equals 1 it starts to dip down
and then it goes back up there's this
turning point what's going on here I'm
interested I guess in two things here
number one what is there a turning point
and number two where is it this is often
the question that we ask locate
stationary points and determine their
nature so we're going to try and unpack
this by using some of our differential
calculus let's come back over here now
if this is the function of interest in
in let's go over to the left so I've got
some space to work if this is the
function I'm interested in how do I
differentiate it well we run into some
problems immediately because you kind of
wanted to yourself well can I treat this
function like my to earlier functions
can I treat it like X to the power of n
function we know let's just make a
little side note here we know that the
derivative of X to the power of n is n X
to the N minus 1 we you know multiply by
the index and then we reduce the index
by 1 well if I tried that over here
could that work well if I said let's
write this in a funny-looking color
let's choose let's just Brown if I
differentiate X to the power of X and
try and bring this down well let's see
if
this actually worked out and gives us a
reasonable result and the first thing is
I'm going to multiply by the index which
in this case is X and then I'm
multiplying that by X ^ and then I
reduce the index by 1 so I get let's see
here
X minus 1 here hmm okay
now interestingly if I think this is the
derivative I can you know work with this
a little more I can actually say well I
have index laws right and this is X to
the power of 1 times X to the power of X
minus 1 now when I multiply two numbers
that have the same base I add their
indices so I'm thinking that this will
give me X to the power of X minus 1 plus
1 minus 1 plus 1 that's X to the power
of X now this is problematic this is
once we simplify apparently the function
that we came from but that can't be
right because we know that the functions
that have you know their derivatives
being themselves are the family of
functions that are Exponential's Ede the
power of x and the fact other functions
like that either power of X you know
shifted left and right and all the rest
so this doesn't match this doesn't seem
right and we can also see that this must
be wrong because if we come over here
and try and think about well what would
it mean for this function to be its own
derivative we know something is
definitely wrong because if we let me
take a screenshot so I can write on this
if we have a look at this part of the
function over here this part of the
function went a bit too far maybe maybe
go back to about there I'd say this part
of the function is clearly decreasing
it's going down so it's derivative or
its gradient function should be negative
at that point but we can see we're
looking at X to the power of X right now
it's never negative so this is a bust
this is no good so let's get rid of this
this is not the derivative I clearly
this approach that I used here to use
our our derivative of a polynomial it's
not going to work this is not a
polynomial X to the power of X so I have
to abandon this so let's get rid of this
approach it
no good now I can then say well maybe
it's a little bit more like a function
on the right maybe I should treat this
more as an exponential now when we have
two to the power of X or ADA power of X
we know that we can say the derivative
of a to the power of X is going to be a
to the X log a hmm okay a to the X log a
so would this work can I try this out
with this function well if I think let's
go back to my Brown working before if I
think that this might work let's just
see what happens this is actually a
really important thing in working
mathematically even though you know you
might think something will go wrong
you actually will learn something by
giving a shot anyway so let's let's just
see where this will lead us if I treat
this in the same way then I'm going to
get I guess X to the power of X log X
mm-hmm okay well let's see what happens
if I give this a go this is so be
interesting if I come back to our
function over here what does X to the
power of X log X look like X raise that
to the power of X and then I'm going to
multiply that by I'm going to go into my
functions here and it's gonna be
something like log X all right now what
is going on here now this is much more
interesting to me but it's you've got a
problem and you'll see why in a second
let's it's interesting to me because if
i zoom out this for starters has it it
does something that I wanted the
previous derivative to do which it
didn't do namely there's a part of this
derivative the gradient function which
is green is a part of that is negative
that should make us have a decreasing
function now I do have part of it that's
decreasing but it doesn't quite match
does it let's again take a screenshot so
we can draw in this thing if I have a
look over here where is the gradient
function negative well I'm yellow
because it's a more helpful contrasting
color this part down here this is where
the gradient function is negative so
therefore I would expect that the
function it came from which I
differentiated it should be decreasing
for this whole time
I'm close but I'm not quite there am i
if you have a look at the red function
above its decreasing for part of that
yellow section but not for the whole
part if you have a look at this part
here you know the function has gone back
to increasing again and the derivative
down there well yeah it's not positive
like it should be so this is a bust as
well let's get rid of this guy because
it isn't what we want so now we've
established that our way of
differentiating polynomials doesn't work
a way of differentiating Exponential's
which have a you know base like a it
doesn't work either doesn't give us the
result we want so what can we do